you are combining data with knowledge
yeah and that that requires a changing
approach and in particular causal
knowledge yeah help explain sort of
biases
um missing data so it's all about uh
looking for explanations it's it's not
just your classical number crunching
which is what most statisticians do you
know we we're looking for causal
explanations why the data is is what it
is yeah so if I uh this is going to be a
little bit challenging since most of uh
the Dark Horse followership is probably
listening on audio we're not going to do
any visuals here and they would be uh
important if we were going to do an
exhaustive explanation of
um the Bayesian approach but just to
take one reducto ad absurdum if you had
a test for smallpox that was uh 99
accurate in the positive direction
and you gave it to a random person in
Los Angeles today and they came up
positive that would not say they had a
99 chance of having smallpox because
smallpox as far as we know is not
anywhere in circulation the percentage
of the population that has it at zero
yeah so you would have to be very
skeptical of that positive even though
the test itself might be uh
chemically very effective at detecting
small Pockets yeah in that case it could
be like 99.9 Acura I mean the key thing
is this is where people get in fact even
with during the covert debate with the
false positives on the PCR testing it's
a very relevant question because Bayes
comes in here it's all about it's it's
it's all very well having a small
probability of a false positive so you
might it might only be you know well
under one percent chance that if you
don't have the disease you don't have
the virus or smallpox in your example
that you're wrongly test positives it's
you know it's 99 of the time when you
when you don't have it it gives you the
right answer right so it seems like it's
really accurate but of course if if the
incidence right is let's say one in a
thousand of course a small box it's even
lower but just let's suppose with covert
it's one in a thousand right what that
means is that in a thousand if you take
10 000 people
right only about 10 of them
will have the disease but of the other
990 or whatever you're going to get this
one percent false positive rates you're
going to get 19 about 99 of those who
don't have the disease testing positive
so you've got about 110 testing positive
of whom only about 10 generally have the
disease so the probability that you've
got the disease having tested positive
is actually less than 10 percent
and people it's just been such a problem
explaining this route so people saying
we know they say they we we know that
the the false positive rate for PCR
testing is is less than one percent it's
only point three percent you know you
know less than a third of a percent so
how can you turn around and say that a
lot of people are asymptomatic or test
positive haven't got the disease this
rubbish but of course no we know that we
know from empirical data we've actually
got data on asymptomatics and whether or
not they they're testing with false
positives or not and like over 80 of
them were tested positive did not have a
virus they really were false positives
wow well I I must tell you one of the
things that Heather and I scratch our
heads about all the time is that we are
what two and a half years into this
pandemic and the testing is still so
crude and our understanding of what it
implies is so poor how can that possibly
be
I think that the the testing was always
part of the creating the narrative I
mean look I I how did I first get into
trouble as it were how was I first
labeled
murder of misinformation during this
whole thing it was actually when the
mass testing started in the UK in the
late summer of 2020.
and that was mass testing of
asymptomatic people for whom we knew
that you know a high proportion weren't
going to be having the virus but they
were reports they started to report they
were as it would always just reported
case numbers so you look at the
government dashboard and you see this
increasing number of case numbers right
and a case is just a positive someone
testing positive on a PCR tests right so
I'm looking to say how do I say this is
going right up but actually it's the
intestines going up so let's just divide
let's perform the radical Act of simple
division we'll divide the number of
cases by the number of tests and when
you do that you see actually there
wasn't much of an ink flat yeah but that
radical Act of simple division is what
casts made as a spreader of
misinformation and from that point on
that was that was the you know that was
the end of my sort of academic
credibility as far as you know as far as
the the uh accepted Academia is
concerned well this is what this is one
of the things that's so upsetting to me
is that yes that radical Act of division
doing it per capita and discovering that
your Trend was an artifact
an obvious artifact of the fact that you
were doing more tests and I mean let's
let's take my reducto at absurdum yeah
if we were to play that same game with
smallpox today and we were to start
testing people for smallpox with a
highly accurate test with a very low
false positive rate right and we were to
let's say we set out to test the entire
population well you and I both know what
that would look like we would see the
number of cases of small people you test
the more it goes up right and the fact
is the actual number of cases would be
zero throughout but the number of
apparent cases would be would be
accelerating and we know what the news
narrative would be yeah absolutely the
problem is that as much as it is
difficult to understand Bayesian priors
and all the things that go into a proper
analysis the error that you are
describing is one any high school
student of probability ought to
understand perfectly well so the idea
that our Public Health apparatus got it
wrong
um stretches the bounds of credulity how
could they have missed Capital analysis
was necessary we've done long before
this Alcove thing we also did we were
also involved in some of the you know
studies which looked at the why you know
people get this kind of reasoning wrong
and what's not just acid then various
that is in here but I mean I can give
you so there's lots of studies which
show that you know very highly
intelligent people even people with with
you know quantitative knowledge people
who have kind of like scientific degrees
don't get these don't don't get the
simple Point okay and you know I've also
been involved in a lot of legal work and
this whole thing amounts to What's
called the prosecutor status or where
they they mix the probability of the
evidence the probability of the evidence
given the hypothesis they confuse the
problems of the hypothesis given the
evidence so it's basically the same
thing as what we've been discussing here
which is the assumption that that one
over a hundred that the 99 percent
accuracy is the 99 chance that you do
you don't have them disease so anyway
the point is they get it wrong and I've
I've spoken you know I've spoken with
the top the most brilliant judges for
example in this
and try to give and we give you know
what I think is a very simple like
visual explanation just doing it with
sort of you know stick men you show that
the sort of argument I gave before but
actually showing it so you can really
see and they say and it'll say things
like it doesn't matter how many times
you you say I still I still think it's
wrong I still think that that right yeah
I think you're wrong in your conclusion
I mean the rational phase answer is
wrong according to them right it's
really a question you know I I don't
know that the right Bayesian environment
exists
developmentally for us to develop the
correct intuitions but I think many of
us have looked at the Monty Hall problem
for example yeah and thought
I get it but wow does that feel wrong
every time I go through it you know it
just it just feels off
[Music]